el salvador va a cerrar este año con
aproximadamente 4.500 a 4700
salvadoreños asesinados
eso nos da un índice de homicidios
alrededor del 65 a 100
por población el promedio mundial el
promedio mundial es 6
para niveles epidémicos son arriba de 10
y nosotros cerraremos en 65 entonces
elevemos el reto de un solo
seamos la primera generación de
salvadoreños en ver la paz en este país
y después de escuchar todas estas
maravillosas charlas esa pregunta la
respuesta y a la que me auto respondo es
yo creo que este país puede ver la paz
en los próximos años
durante la segunda guerra mundial
existió un soldado llamado desmond 2 que
es lo que ustedes ven ahí lo ven
relativamente pequeño
débil aparentemente pesaba
aproximadamente 145 150 libras durante
la segunda guerra mundial durante un
periodo entero de 12 horas él fue capaz
de trasladar a 75 de sus compañeros que
fueron heridos en combate y bajarlos a
través de un peñasco desmond 2 era un
soldado muy singular primero era
pacifista y no llevó armas nunca llevó
armas a la guerra lo segundo es que
cuando se le preguntaba que cómo lo hizo
desmond os decía que durante todo el
proceso le estaba viendo a dios que le
diera fuerza para salvar a uno más él
jamás pensó de entrada a voy a salvar a
75 de mis compañeros durante 12 horas
el ejército en lo personal me enseñó a
una temprana edad una cosa que se llama
el punto muerto el punto muerto es
cuando físicamente estás totalmente
desgastado y la gente te está gritando y
otras cosas para que sigas y sigas y
sigas y ese es el punto a donde pasan
dos cosas te das por vencido porque
físicamente ya no puedes más o entras en
una especie de calma mental y en esta
calma mental algo sucede en tu cuerpo
que entras en una fase que llamada el
segundo aire y ese segundo aire es lo
que permite a muchos de nosotros hacer
real realmente cosas maravillosas
creo poder hablar por la inmensa mayoría
de los cirujanos lo que ustedes están
viendo ahí es una cirugía cerebral de
base de cráneo esas cirugías suelen ser
bastante largas 68 horas en la misma
posición tratando de remover pedazos de
tumores de áreas muy delicadas y
entradas las horas en quirófano
empezamos a entrar en una especie de
punto muerto y sabes que estás en este
punto muerto porque las cosas se ponen
más difíciles te empiezan a doler los
hombros los movimientos se vuelven más
torpes y el que te está ayudando o tu
amigo dice mira ya le quitamos
suficiente y déjalo esto está bien así
quedó bien pero tú sabes que abajo de
esas mantas está un hijo
un papá o una mamá
y que tenéis que seguir porque el
resultado de si no sigues puede ser
catastrófico para esa familia y
importante es que lo puedas hacer sin
dañar a las personas
definitivamente con el médico se los
puede decir se lo voy a decir de mi
experiencia como neurocirujano
hay pacientes tan singulares tan
singulares que tú piensas que lo único
que les queda
es fallecer
pero algo pasta en ese paciente que yo
no te lo puede explicar
que empiezan a recuperarse de un punto
extremadamente grave a donde todo se
había perdido y se empiezan a recuperar
de una manera tan rápida que se recupera
más rápido que las personas normales por
lo menos a mi impresión
algunas personas le llaman a esto
casualidad biológica
buena suerte y algunos le llamamos a
estos milagros
lo que sí sabemos es que para pasar del
punto muerto a este segundo aire
de pasar de la desesperanza a la
esperanza se requiere voluntad se
requiere voluntad y es un gran consumo
de energía a nivel cerebral por supuesto
es más fácil darse por vencido es más
fácil tirar tirarse a los leones o es
más fácil simplemente vámonos del país
porque en el país no hay nada que hacer
es más fácil la desesperanza
en esencia el cerebro funciona por vía
de dos caminos el camino más primitivo
le vamos a llamar ganglios de la base en
esta oportunidad que está 100% enfocado
en mi sobrevivencia es decir el actuar
bajo los ganglios de la base
todos los demás ustedes no existen si se
empieza a quemar el teatro yo voy a
salir corriendo de acá porque son mi
kang los de la base los que están
activados entonces al igual que ustedes
pero lo interesante de esto es que hay
otra área mucho más importante mucho más
grande que es nuestra corteza prefrontal
nuestra corteza prefrontal tiene la
capacidad
de darnos y preocuparnos por los demás
tiene la capacidad de entregar unas
cosas maravillosas como los que ustedes
han visto que han presentado los
diseñadores que son pensamientos
divergentes que nos ayudan a encontrar
soluciones a problemas muy complejos
pero también de una área específica que
se llaman los pensamientos flexibles y
los pensamientos flexibles en esencia
tienen que ver en cuanto yo
comprendo un pensamiento diferente al
mío aunque yo no lo lo asimile y no diga
bueno ahora voy a pensar así pero si me
da la capacidad de entender de a dónde
viene ese pensamiento y eso requiere un
montón de energía la área prefrontal
gasta energía y por eso es que a veces
cuesta acceder a ella otra de las cosas
interesantes de este sistema es que
cuando está activada la vía de
sobrevivencia bajo estrés la corteza
prefrontal queda inactiva es decir yo no
puedo pensar en estas cosas filosóficas
si estoy tratando de sobrevivir
en el 2014 las cosas estaban pasando de
una manera espectacular desde el punto
de vista profesional familiar estábamos
estrenando casa con mi esposa nuestro
tercer hijo habían recién nacido pero
había algo que no hacía clic había algo
que se veía se sentía raro yo no
entendía realmente qué era pero estaba
viendo síntomas que ya los había visto
antes sentimientos que ya los había
tenido antes y los había tenido durante
mi infancia
el único problema es que durante mi
infancia el salvador estaba inmerso en
una guerra entonces no me hacía clic se
habíamos firmado los acuerdos de paz en
1992 que era esto que estaba pasando en
el país estábamos entrando en una nueva
guerra o tal vez la guerra que terminó
tan siquiera que era todo esto que
estaba pasando y de ahí comienza una
investigación que se llamó en su momento
gran corrupción pero básicamente lo que
eran corrupción era era ir entrevistar a
corruptos y corruptores a personas no
corruptas a otras que francamente no
eran corruptas en total fueron 88
personas desde la época de los militares
hasta ese momento eran personas de
pensamientos totalmente opuestos pero lo
interesante era que a pesar de que eran
de pensamientos opuestos podías
encontrar patrones en común en lo que te
decían en lo que sentían y en sus tomas
de decisiones lo cual era lo por lo
menos en ese momento lo más interesante
es imagen que está en el medio fue en
este escenario
los que tenemos arriba de 40 cuando
hablábamos de la corrupción y hablamos
de la impunidad por lo menos en el 2014
teníamos miedo a que nos fueran a matar
porque porque así habíamos crecido con
ese temor
en esa foto poca gente lo sabe pero
cuando yo comencé esa charla aquí en el
2014 en el 2015
francamente pensé que me iban a matar
pero afortunadamente no pasó la primera
lección
de esa experiencia de gran corrupción
fue que el problema nunca fue ideológico
el problema acá nunca fue de derecha y
de izquierda y mira que ahí vienen los
indios y vienen los comunistas y vienen
las arcas ahí vienen los terroristas los
socialistas los conservadores y los
liberales todos esos términos existen no
cabe duda
pero ninguno de esos términos amerita
que nos estemos matando en este país
la primera lección es que el problema
siempre fue biológico la toma de
decisiones estaba basada en los ganglios
de la base y cuando yo estoy tomando una
decisión de los ganglios de la base yo
soy el bueno y todos ustedes son los
malos porque piensan diferente a mí
el problema es que cuando nos paramos
del otro lado me decían exactamente lo
mismo ellos eran los buenos y todos los
demás eran los malos entonces esas
fueron grandes lecciones que nosotros
empezamos a ver que si teníamos cosas en
común aunque pensáramos diferentes y
fuéramos de ideologías diferentes tal
vez teníamos un lugar para encontrar una
tierra que nos hiciera llegar a la paz
más rápido la segunda lección
cuando yo comenzaba estas charlas
comenzaba con un mal chiste y les decía
miren cuando van a hablar con un
neurocirujano y saben que no vamos a
hablar de neurocirugía y vamos a hablar
de otras cosas el país realmente está
mal hasta que me topé como una líder
entrar en sus 70 años una verdadera
líder que se me quedó bien y mejor y eso
que me o si yo me metí a proteger a mi
país siendo un ama de casa o sea que me
lleva ventaja y ahí tendí lo más
importante y los que les quiero dejar a
ustedes todos todos los que estamos aquí
tenemos algo que aportar tenemos por qué
aportar desde las ciencias básicas como
neurocirujanos como agricultores como
amas de aspac como hijos pero todos
tenemos responsabilidad de aportar para
construir un país que realmente viva en
paz
y la tercera lección la cual fue
probablemente la más dura para mí por lo
menos aprender porque me tardo casi 40
en entenderlo
y esta afección fue que en primer lugar
los salvadoreños no nos vemos iguales
yo no me veo igual con la aunque la
persona que está en la calle y mucho
menos con la persona que trabaje en mi
casa yo me veo diferente
si yo no me veo igual a esa persona por
consecuencia yo no la quiero
si tuviera que resumir la causa de la
violencia del país a través de los
ganglios de la base bien fácil no nos
queremos y lo hemos demostrado
consistentemente a lo largo de nuestra
historia
si no nos queremos tampoco queremos al
país
yo quiero el salvador con mis ideas pero
no obtuvo ni tampoco el tuyo de ese no
quiero yo quiero el mío y si se
recuerdan los ganglios de la base y
viven la corteza prefrontal a dónde está
el pensamiento flexible y el pensamiento
flexible quiere decir que tenemos que
generar un país a donde todos quepamos y
adonde todos nos querramos finalmente
eso lleva a un lugar que
psicológicamente se sabe y es un lugar
muy oscuro
y es la humillación extrema la razón de
la violencia de este país es la
humillación extrema y la humillación
extrema se da cuando grandes sectores de
la población están de privados de lo más
elemental ya lo oyeron en cuanto al agua
pero llegamos a otro punto más tenebroso
la seguridad física
no hay nada
que un padre puede hacer
en contra de un grupo de personas que
van a llegar en la noche
y se van a llevar a mi hija no me puedo
ni imaginar cómo se de sentir eso
en general solo para sacar del mito una
cosa
la empatía son ganglios de la base
actuando la empatía es lo más básico del
ser humano salvo que tengas una lesión
en el cerebro la inmensa mayoría de
nosotros somos capaces de sentir el
dolor ajeno' si vemos a un niño
sufriendo en la calle lo vemos y decimos
muy pobrecito cómo está sufriendo si
vemos personas en dolor nosotros lo
vamos a sentir esa es la famosa empatía
pues la empatía no basta
hay que ir más allá de la empatía
tarde cambiar eso y realmente hacer un
esfuerzo para cambiarlo requiere nuestra
corteza prefrontal un gasto energético
más grande porque ahí encontramos una
cosa que se llama la compasión
cómo se ve la paz en el salvador como ya
expliqué no tengo ni idea porque ninguno
de ustedes lo ha visto ni yo tampoco
pero eso no quiere decir que no tengamos
la obligación
de transmitir un ideal de poderle
transmitir ese ideal a nuestros hijos y
que ellos en conjunto con nosotros nos
ayuden a construir ese país lo que sí sé
es que se construye un metro cuadrado a
la vez para muchos de los que estamos
acá no es un metro o un kilómetro o diez
kilómetros pero el hecho es que todos
tenemos algo que aportar
finalmente el otro reto que les dejo
querramos tanto tanto a nuestro país y a
nuestros compatriotas aunque piensen
diferente a nosotros
que el próximo presidente de este país
sea que éste sea quien sea nos haya
gustado o no si él actúa con rectitud y
transparencia
ayudémosles a ganar el premio nobel de
la paz imagínense eso un presidente
salvadoreño gasto donado con el premio
nobel de la paz
no obstante si el próximo presidente de
este país sea quien sea se corrompe
querramos tanto tanto a nuestro país ya
nuestros vecinos para no volver a
quedarnos callados y convirtámonos en
astillas en sus manos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]